now that we've had a little bit more
time to review Donald Trump's Attorney
General William bars for page summary of
the Moller investigation we're starting
to get a sense of the full scope of the
absurdity and dishonesty of it and we're
gonna go through it in some detail today
now later I will let you know
I guess I'm letting you know now but
we'll get into it in more detail that
the Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell has already blocked a
resolution to release the full Moeller
investigation report and this is one
data point that is increasingly
illuminating what it is that is taking
place here there's an attorney and
professor at University of New Hampshire
named Seth Abramson who put together a
really great Twitter thread down to the
fine grit detail of how William bars for
Paige Muller investigation summary is
essentially a total scam or sham use
whichever or both words that you want
and to really understand this we do have
to get into some detail and I'm going to
do my best to sort of ballpark it for
you and then give you some specific
examples because I want everybody to
understand it
I don't want people's eyes to glaze over
but I also want to do it in a way that
doesn't ignore the detail so William
Barr put out a four-page document the
first page of which we're putting on the
screen for our audience and one really
important thing to understand is that
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bar published not a summary of the
investigation
William bar published a summary of the
summary of the investigation now you
might be saying David you're already
sort of losing me here what I mean by
that is that Robert Muller did the
investigation which includes all sorts
of raw evidence case files testimony
pages and pages and pages of evidence
Robert Moeller then wrote a report a
summary we could call it which he sent
to William Barr presumably Muller sent
both the case files meaning all the data
and the evidence as well as his summary
to William Barr he
not half but let's assume that he did
William bar summarized the summary not
the evidence and included just pieces of
four sentences from Robert molars
summary of his own investigation okay so
it's a summary of a summary rather than
a summary of the in full investigation
data why do we care about that the
reason we care is because Robert molars
summary is only about decisions made
either to prosecute or not to prosecute
without the further underlying evidence
so I'll give you an example to try to
make this crystal clear but Robert
molars summary of the investigation
could say based on all the evidence
about obstruction I decided I could not
prosecute Trump but I also cannot
exonerate him fine however if we looked
at the raw evidence from the
investigation it might indicate that
Robert Muller had for example 80 percent
of what he needed to prosecute Donald
Trump for obstruction Muller gives bar a
summary which says I didn't have enough
to indict on obstruction you might need
95 percent to indict on obstruction but
bar because he's summarizing a summary
says merely that there was not evidence
to indict for obstruction and implies
that there was not any evidence that
Donald Trump Trump obstructed justice
it's tricky wording so many people
simply don't notice the difference but
it's extraordinarily important the
strategic decision that William bar made
and he has a lot of experience in this
as an article from Tom Hartman tells us
which we'll deal with later on in the
program Barr made the strategic decision
to summarize the summary because it will
foment the idea of it's very binary was
there collusion or wasn't there
collusion is the president exonerated or
is the president not exonerated and if
we actually saw the full case file we
would almost certainly see a ton of
evidence supporting criminality by
Donald Trump and associates on many
fronts
but likely not enough for Moeller to
independently make the decision to
prosecute there's a sort of analogy that
we could imagine with burglary
imagine that robert muller was hired to
investigate burglary and if you look at
his raw case file that lists all of the
evidence he might say okay the alleged
burglar was in the location was spotted
in the location at the time and the
alleged burglar was previously someone
who had provided a service it was the
Cable Guy at the house that was
ultimately burglarized and the burglar
was caught with some piece of paper that
looks like it came from the house that
was burglarized but I ultimately can't
prove this beyond a reasonable doubt
because the surveillance footage doesn't
show the burglar
if Muller summarizes that Muller would
say I am unable to establish beyond a
reasonable doubt that this individual
committed the burglary
if bar comes in and summarizes the
summary you can imply that there was no
evidence whatsoever when in fact as I've
just described to you there was evidence
but not enough to establish beyond a
reasonable doubt that an indictment was
relevant let me give you another example
of a really important semantic game that
William bar plays here if you look at
the last paragraph of page one of bars
summary it says that the special counsel
thoroughly investigated allegations of
conspiracy with the Russian government
to interfere in the 2016 election and
later it says that they didn't find
evidence of that this is an important
vocabulary distinction Moeller was not
meant to investigate merely conspiracy
if you go back to the appointment of the
special counsel and we're putting that
up on the screen which outlines exactly
what the special counsel is supposed to
be doing it says very clearly under
paragraph B subsection 1 that the
special counsel is investigating any
links and/or
ordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign let's go back to
the bar report again the bar report as
written by William bar references only
investigating conspiracy conspiracy is
only one way in which there could be
coordination or links and its way
narrower than the full scope of what
Robert Muller was looking at and once
again because William bar is summarizing
Moeller's summary and not the evidence
all of the possible evidence for links
and for coordination simply aren't
mentioned by bar bar says conspiracy was
investigated that means agreements of
some kind for illegal purposes you could
have links you could have coordination
and still not have conspiracy bar is
being deceptive by being overly specific
which is a common way that people can
obfuscate underlying evidence and a Seth
Abramson says bar is adopting Trump's
very specific definition of collusion
the narrowest possible definition
referring only to the crime of
conspiracy and says there was an
evidence of that which justified an
indictment this is a sham okay now let
me give you another example of how wacky
we now recognize this four-page report
to be bar starts to mix and confuse
legal language which sounds sort of
innocuous to the average layperson but
it's not okay in the same paragraph of
his report Barr says that Moeller did
not find that the Trump campaign
conspired with or coordinated with
Russia but then when he quotes from
Muller's summary says the investigation
did not establish that members of trumps
campaign conspired establish is a term
with a very specific legal meaning
establish with enough evidence to
justify an indictment or to indicate
that a particular crime has been
committed
did not find witches bars language
suggests
0% evidence if you look at the
underlying case file that molar has
where as did not establish could mean
50% proof could mean 60% proof could
mean 80% proof it could be anything
short of what you would need for an
indictment sort of beyond reasonable
doubt these are legal games that bar is
an expert in playing which we're going
to get to later he has a long history of
this there's much more I couldn't
possibly cover all of it in one segment
or even in one show so in the
description to the YouTube clip for this
story we're linking to Seth Abramson's
tweet thread bottom line the report is a
sham every hour that goes by we learn
more about the ways in which it is a
sham and to be clear I've been saying it
for more than a year we actually have a
phone call I got a year ago which will
play for you tomorrow to prove that I've
been saying it for more than a year this
doesn't mean that Donald Trump
personally colluded with Vladimir Putin
we were never expecting that what it
tells us is that william bars summary of
molars summary is an absolute and total
joke playing a lot of the very common
legalese games that people try to play
when they want to either widen the scope
to their advantage or narrow the scope
to their advantage depending on the
circumstances one can be more
advantageous than the other and most
importantly if the actual underlying
evidence case files and report from
Moeller truly exonerate trump released
the report which Mitch McConnell has
already blocked as I will tell you about
later on in today's program let me know
your reaction and your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show much more
on this coming up every time I buy one
of those variety packs of socks there's
something in there that I like not quite
as much as the rest of what's in the
package but with dollar sock crew you
can build your own pack of socks
starting as low as a dollar sixty a pair
you can choose from classic patterns or
quirky vibrant ones shop dollar sock
crew calm now and
receive 30% off your first order with
the code Pakman that's dollar sock crew
dot-com code PA k ma n